il est des dates dans la vie que l'on
n'oublie pas pour ma part c'était le 17
juillet 2010 9 17 juillet 2019 c'était
un mercredi matin et après neuf années
de réflexion sur la maternité
j'allais enfin accouché par voie postale
de mon travail doctorales je reviens en
arrière je me suis un peu ce pôle et de
ce travail doctorales et comme la vie
est parfois magnifiquement orchestrée
c'est au moment précis n'ont pas la
veille ni le lendemain
mais au moment précis du rendu sur ce
travail de la maternité que sonna
l'heure du début d'un autre travail
le réel travail de la maternité vous
l'aurez compris la décontraction
psychique fut de très courte durée et
décontraction d'un physique prirent le
relais
alors je vous rassure tout de suite je
vis si rondement vous parler de mon
accouchement doctorale bien évidemment
et plus précisément de la mère que j'ai
de prêt à étudier et plus précisément
encore de la mère de koor à savoir
celles qui portent et accouche celle par
laquelle on est nécessairement qu'on
l'appelle ou pas maman puisque s'il est
une certitude
un point commun universel entre tout un
chacun
d'hier à aujourd'hui c'est que nous
venons tous du corps d'une femme qui
nous a portés et que l'on appelle
traditionnellement la mer puisque hormis
en cas d'adoption c'est bel et bien
naturellement le corps qui fait la mer
d'où ce célèbre adage roman que vous
connaissez peut-être mater semper
certains est la mère est toujours
certaines puisqu'elle porte et accouche
ça se voit et ça se sent évidemment
une évidence qui en 1804 avec le code
civil de napoléon a été remise en
question puisque on instituait
nouvellement la maternité non plus à
partir du corps mais à partir du mariage
pour être mère il fallait être épouse
puis un siècle et demi après mais bien
la réforme de 1972 imi interne
pourquoi pourquoi parce que déjà la
sécurité promise par le mariage
déclinée il fallait donc en revenir à
quelque chose de plus sûr pour établir
la maternité on en revenait donc au
corps à ce que la juriste marcela iacub
appelle l' empire du ventre
cet empire dû vendre qui va être encore
remis en question en bref depuis lors
jusqu'à de nos jours ce qui fait la mer
c'est le fait d'accoucher
à moins qu'elle n'y renonce une évidence
qui va être remise encore en question à
partir des années 80 et des techniques
de procréation les développements qu'il
ya dans ce champ car si l'identité
féminine n'a cessé au cours de
l'histoire de prendre ses distances avec
son corps au nom de l'égalité au nom de
la liberté de gagner en maîtrise eh bien
ces évolutions vont plus que jamais
provoqué à repenser le corps de la
maternité à l'épreuve de la volonté ça
doit vous parlez surtout en ces temps
amp aide médicale à la procréation pma
procréation médicalement assistée
ce sont des techniques comme
l'insémination artificielle ou comme la
fécondation in vitro qui vise à pallier
des difficultés pour concevoir sans
jamais mettre question l'évidence de
l'accouchement puisque celles qui
portent demeure la mer néanmoins et bien
le premier principe de loi de bioéthique
qui a été adoptée le 27 septembre
dernier et qui ouvre la pma aux femmes à
toutes les femmes et bien cesse de faire
valoir
l'accouchement comme le premier principe
unique ultime de la filiation maternelle
puisque désormais sur l'acte de
naissance figureront au même titre ces
deux titres de maires et maires ce qui
signifie donc au même titre la volonté
d'être mère pour l'une et le corps pour
l'autre feront la mer au risque que
cette extension de la définition
juridique de la maternité n'ouvre la
voie à l'expansion de la volonté dans le
champ de la maternité n'ouvre la voie à
la gpa gestation pour autrui alors la
gestation pour autrui c'est en somme
l'extension polémique de la paix m la
gestation pour autrui est autorisée dans
de nombreux pays mais elle est toujours
prohibé en france et ça vient d'être
renouvelée par la majorité pour le
moment du moins alors contrairement à la
pma la gpa rompt avec l'évidence de
l'accouchement puisque le corps ne fait
plus la mer ce qui fait la mer c'est la
volonté
d'où la distinction entre la gestatrice
celle qui porte l'enfant qu'on associe
même parfois une nounou et la mère dit
d'intention
une à noter que cette intentionnalité
d'être mère prime sur tout ce qui touche
au corps que ce soit le corps de la
gestatrice qui portent ou même de la
génétique puisque la mère d'intention
pourrait avoir recours aussi une
donneuse d'ovocytes
bon je vous ai dit tout ça et vous
pourriez me rétorquer est alors tant
mieux peut-être non si enfin la volonté
prime sur le corps après tant d'années
d'aliénation si la maternité se définit
par la volonté alors j'avais envie de
vous soumettre une question si demain
effectivement la grossesse ne fait plus
la mer si la femme qui passe devant vous
avec ce ventre rond n'est pas la mère de
l'enfant qu'elle porte alors qu'elle le
porte
n'est ce pas à craindre que dans
l'avenir quelque chose ne tourne plus
rond
du moins dans le rapport que nous
engageons avec le corps et notre vécu
car s'il est donc née il ya de nombreux
risques
alors je les ai pas tous évoqué je ne
vais pas tous est évoqué quand on parle
de gpa vis-à-vis de l'enfant vis-à-vis
de la gestatrice l'abandon la
marchandisation la domination conçoit
pour qu'on soit content que ce soit
justifié ça change en fonction des pays
il est dans tous les cas un point qu
engendre des facto la gpa puisqu'il
repose sur cela c'est
l'instrumentalisation du corps en ce1
aussi bien du côté du couple demandeur
que du côté du corps social qui autorise
cette pratique que du côté de la
gestatrice elle même qui de son propre
gré ou non instrumentalise et utilise
son corps alors on est fini dans cet
environnement et ça pose de nombreuses
questions notamment sur la maîtrise du
corps comme si finalement dans un monde
comme le nôtre où le corps n'a de cesse
de devenir la vitrine de notre volonté
la grossesse
devait elle aussi joué le jeu et penser
à travers le prisme de la maîtrise comme
si on pouvait maîtriser la dose
d'affection standard à investir dans
cette expérience là comme si le corps se
maîtrisait or je crois que s'il est une
certitude c'est que le corps nous
rappelle tout au long de
notre vie à sa propre vulnérabilité
aussi et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle si le corps est vulnérable si
le corps est faillible
avec toutes ces problématiques
d'instrumentalisation d'utilisation du
corps de marchandisation
pourquoi ne pas à l'avenir cheminer vers
l'idée de s'en passer
je crois qu'on est dans une époque qui
donne au corps encore plus à ce fantasme
qui plus est à l'ère du virtuel à celui
de l'extra corporel vous pourriez bien
mais ça ne tourne pas rond l'extra
corporelle bas après tout si la
grossesse ne fait plus la mer si la
grossesse n'est qu'une fonction et
histoire d'en dispenser les gestatrices
et toutes les histoires que cela suscite
pourquoi ne pas s'en passer pourquoi ne
pas passer d'une maternité
traditionnellement et naturellement
affiliée au corps à une maternité
d'intention qui se détache du corps à la
perspective d'une maternité ce encore
imaginer et si nous naissions plus du
corps d'une femme et si nous naissions
plus du corps d'une femme alors c'est la
perspective je reviendrai sur l'utérus
artificiel
puisque on était de l'artificialisation
de l'utérus avec la gestation pour
autrui à la perspective de l'utérus
artificiel une perspective à laquelle
donner corps aldous huxley en 1931 dans
le meilleur des mondes
actuellement cela est expérimenté
notamment aux états unis à partir de
foetus d'agneau et les chercheurs
américains prédisent que ce dispositif
pourrait être accessible à l'humain sous
une dizaine d'années ce qui est quand
même absolument passionnant alors je le
précise dans un but thérapeutique sauver
des enfants prématurés ce qui serait
évidemment un grand pas pour l'humanité
mais on observe on le
les techniques de procréation déborde
inévitablement le champ du thérapeutique
on le voit aujourd'hui avec le marché à
l'international des gamètes pour
rejoindre celui du désir
et si demain la femme pouvait choisir
d'être mère s'emporter vous pouvez
choisir de porter sans être mère et si
demain on pouvait ne plus avoir à penser
à l'horloge biologique et si demain
enfin la maternité se penser à l'égal de
la paternité
indépendamment du corps après tout dans
une société qui évolue pourquoi la
définition de la maternité n'évoluerait
tel pas c'est une vaste question
serait ce là un succès pour l'égalité
quid de l'équité quid de la différence
de l'indifférence
il faut vivre avec son monde on va pas
en faire tout un monde
alors moi je m'inquiète toujours de ce
genre d'argument d'arguments qui
consiste à dire il faut vivre avec son
temps
tant qu'il est temps d'agir dans de
nombreux genres al'inverse il faut
battre en brèche catégoriquement
vis-à-vis de toutes ces brèches ouvertes
je m'inquiète aussi de ceux qui en garde
mémoire du passé et bien au culte toutes
les avancées possibles au niveau du fer
famille de demain et ses évolutions
alors oui il faut évoluer mais avec
raison garder avec humilité avec
lucidité car s'il est une question
fondamentale
ça concerne me semble-t-il le devenir de
notre rapport instrumentale au corps et
à son vécu
pourquoi et bien pensé à cela
à l'instar du mal de terre mal de terre
ladite mère nature qui appelle
aujourd'hui plus que jamais la volonté
humaine à prendre soin de son corps
je m'interroge je me questionne n'est-il
pas déjà venu le temps de prendre à bras
le corps
celui qui nous portent nécessairement du
moins jusqu alors car qu'en sera-t-il
demain si demain on s'en sert si demain
progressivement on le perd
qu'en sera-t-il demain de la mer la mer
vous savez c'est le point de repère en
mer qu'en sera-t-il demain de la mer ce
point de repère qu'est la mère de koor
le corps de la mère depuis toujours
imaginé naître à tout prix mettre
d'aucun autre naître d'aucune femmes
quid du rapport à soi quid du rapport au
monde
quid du rapport aux autres quid des
corps qui nous porte
là où la volonté l'emportent à corps
perdu vertigineuse perspective non non
symptomatiques me semble-t-il de ce que
je qualifierais de mal de mer de notre
temps un mal de mer qui bien au-delà de
la femme nous concerne tous concerne les
hommes avec un grand h et son ancrage au
monde au sein des corps du monde
c'est pourquoi face à tant de pourquoi
je choisis pour tourner rond plutôt qu
en rond de regarder l'endroit du corps
garder la main pour ne pas perdre pied
et vous voici
[Applaudissements]